cancelled and delayed flights long lines
and packed planes have become the new
normal for air travel which is worrying
some travelers this holiday season like
i have been in line for almost an hour i
have not moved in early october
southwest canceled more than 2 000
flights over the span of three days due
to scheduling problems later that month
american airlines said staffing
shortages contributed to the more than 1
900 flights scrubbed during halloween
weekend you know we've seen generally
you know more delays more cancelled
flights and you know several really bad
episodes where there were kind of
cascades of cancellations that resulted
in you know thousands of flights being
canceled over a couple of day period so
what exactly is driving all of these
airline disruptions and what problems
will passengers face as we head towards
the holidays
so air travel really was pretty much
dormant last year through the pandemic
hardly anybody was traveling and then
that changed really dramatically this
past spring like many industries
struggling with an increasingly tight
labor market airlines are facing
staffing shortages while the airlines
got a lot of government money last year
to keep all their employees
working or on the payroll at least you
know they really just had not enough
for all of those employees to do and
they were concerned you know how long is
the pandemic going to last so
they encouraged really
urged a lot of employees who were close
to retirement to retire early or they
ask people to take long-term leads of
absence you know sometimes for a couple
of years now airlines are racing to
bring back workers and hire pilots
flight attendants and ground staff but
hiring has been difficult as companies
face fiercer competition for certain
roles you know they are sort of seeing
some strains in some of these positions
like ground workers and ramp workers and
customer service and all the other
thousands of people that
are needed to make an airline run but
you know suddenly a lot of those
potential employees have a lot of other
options meanwhile the added burden of
extra shifts and longer hours for the
workers companies do have can lead to
higher rates of staff burnout and sick
leave so you know for the employees who
are there you know some of them are
complaining about
new levels of strain especially over the
summer and the last couple of months
airlines like at southwest have been
saying that they're having problems with
higher rates of sick leave and
absenteeism and some of that might be
due to covid
as a result worker unions have become
more vocal about another issue
disrupting air travel scheduling
mismanagement typical hiccups that may
have normally delayed a flight for one
day turn into multi-day meltdowns caused
by staff scheduling holes consider this
domino effect over optimistic flight
scheduling in the midst of a staffing
shortage may lead to employees being
overworked creating higher levels of
staff burnout and sick leave and leading
to even more scheduling issues and
cancelled flights pilots have said you
know maybe they're a little bit
reluctant
to pick up extra trips you know when
there's an option to pick up some
overtime because if you thought you'd be
willing to work a three-day trip but if
it turns into a six-day trip
unexpectedly you're going to have a
problem what we want to see is is more
efficient scheduling that goes on
during these irregular operations in a
november 13th memo to flight attendants
southwest airlines said it was adding
more reserve crews to support the
reliability of its scheduling of course
external factors like bad weather or
technical issues play a role in airline
disruptions too but now these issues are
compounded by staffing shortages and
scheduling issues creating chain
reactions that can leave thousands of
passengers stranded you know americans
said it got
knocked off course by some a couple of
days of really high winds in dallas and
that resulted in traffic management
programs in dallas that led to fewer
flights being able to take off from
there and that kind of backed up their
whole system american airlines says it
is proactively canceling flights to
provide more scheduling certainty for
crews you know airlines are trying to do
things to make sure that people
do keep showing up to work and they have
the staffing they need
airlines are expecting a surge in
holiday bookings amid declining coven 19
cases and rising vaccination rates but
fuller planes and more robust flight
schedules often mean more difficulties
when things go wrong to avoid staffing
pitfalls and scheduling challenges some
airlines have scaled back flight options
that's something we've seen with
southwest it just has fewer flights than
it used to
so
when it does have something go wrong and
it doesn't need to put people on other
place to try and help them get where
they need to go if flights are full that
can be more difficult and they're just
fewer recovery options something else to
consider when preparing for holiday
travel smaller airports may be
overwhelmed by an increase in travelers
so there's been a lot more demands for
leisure travel to places in florida you
know depending on the time of year to
ski destinations or places out west or
national parks and that just means some
of these airports that had historically
been pretty small or maybe not had huge
traffic numbers are now just seeing an
influx of new airlines adding service
more flights more passengers
meanwhile more crowds can also mean more
unruly passengers
the federal aviation administration
reported over 5 000 passenger disputes
so far this year so travelers flying
this holiday season are reminded to pack
some patience everyone's kind of going
through it together a little bit i guess
i think we're all just gonna have to
kind of learn how to do this again
you